a golpe de estado para evitar una guerra
civil y detención del primer ministro
abdalá ja mdo para protegerle estos
fueron los argumentos del martes del
comandante en jefe del ejército abdel
fattah vulcan antes de la liberación
dejando que su esposa a quien tendió la
mano mientras otros ministros siguen
detenidos
esperamos el que siga con nosotros con
el pueblo de sudán con la transición
tras disolver todas las instituciones
burhan prometió seguir con la transición
democrática que vive sudán desde 2019
sin embargo las manifestaciones
continuaron este martes
lo que derrocaron al brutal régimen de
omar al bashir que tenía mucho más poder
que buscan son muy capaces de derrocarle
en unas pocas horas
este manifestante se refería a los
países occidentales de la comunidad
internacional que se han mostrado
contrarios al golpe como eeuu que
suspendió 700 millones de dólares de
ayuda a sudan
este nuevo golpe se produce tan sólo dos
años después de que masivas protestas
llevasen a derrocar al dictador omar al
bashir en ese momento civiles y
militares se repartieron el poder en una
transición que debe culminar con las
elecciones de julio de 2023